[Music]
[Narrator:] Rat killing combined with basic
measures of ratproofing and sanitation
constitutes a major step in permanent rat
control, but rat killing by itself does not
result in permanent rat control.
So long as food sources and harborage remain
undisturbed, killing rats merely
lessens competition for those that survive.
With less competition, rapid reproduction
rebuilds the population.
Soon, the infestation is as great as ever.
When a building has been ratproofed to keep
rats out, it is possible to eliminate all
rats within the premises by the techniques of rat killing.
It is the rat eradicator's job to get rid
of every last rat remaining in the premises.
One surviving pregnant female might cause
a re-infestation that would completely
nullify the effort and expense of ratproofing.
The tools of rat killing are various rodenticides
and mechanical devices.
The selection and use of these tools depends
upon the area to be made rat-free.
For instance, in this rat-proofed restaurant
kitchen, no chances should be taken with
the poison that rats might spread to human food.
In this case, red squill is selected as the
rodenticide.
Red squill is relatively safe around humans
and most domestic animals, since it is in itself
an emetic and is normally regurgitated before
lasting harm is done.
But the rat cannot regurgitate and retains
the poison.
For this reason, red squill is the most commonly
used rodenticide.
But the problem is to get the rat to eat the
red squill.
Red squill is bitter; therefore, it must be
mixed with food that is highly acceptable to rats.
A poison bait is prepared of fresh, lean ground beef
and chicken mash mixed with red squill.
Salad oil is added as a binder.
The mixture is prepared in small amounts called
torpedoes for distribution to the rats.
An alternate cereal poison bait is prepared
of steamed rolled oats, ground bacon, and red squill.
Experience has shown that better results are
obtained if a choice of food baits
is offered to the rats.
Again salad oil is used as a binder.
The preparation must be made attractive to
the prospective customer.
The cereal and meat base are wrapped in contrasting paper so that the eradication man
can distinguish one from the other and thus can learn which bait the rats prefer.
The poisoned baits must be placed where the
rats can easily find them.
It would be too much to expect the rats to
search for them.
Bait is placed along runways and near customary
sources of food.
To kill as many rats as possible before they
develop an aversion to the poison,
a generous supply of bait is used.
Rats seek food where they have previously
found it.
They are usually suspicious of any change.
However, in the absence of their regular food,
hunger will induce them to accept any food
they can find.
Rats in the open are normally nibblers and
samplers.
They usually eat a full meal only in the safety
of their harborage.
For this reason the torpedoes are made in
a convenient size for the rats
to carry away for later eating.
Each torpedo contains enough rodenticide so
that if later it is shared by two or three
other rats, each rat will receive a lethal
dose.
Red squill takes from 24 to 72 hours to kill.
When a rat has eaten red squill, it usually
becomes lethargic in one to two hours.
Four to 14 hours later, characteristic tremors
begin, followed by progressive paralysis.
If it can, the rat will return to its harborage.
Thus death usually occurs in the nest.
Since up to 90 percent of all rats poisoned
with red squill tend to die in their nests
or in secluded places, it is difficult to
determine how many rats have been killed.
A checkup in the restaurant kitchen two days
after setting out the poison reveals lessened
rat activity, but definite odor of dead rat
coming from behind the stove
guides the eradication man to one of the rat
casualties.
Hmmm...another rat, dead before it could get
to its nest.
Judging from the smell, there must be still
another rat in the hole.
Unfortunately, it is out of reach in the double
wall.
Ripping out the wall would be expensive.
The best thing to do is to cover the odor
with a masking agent such as isoborneol acetate.
Have all the rats been killed?
That's hardly likely.
The best way of finding out whether any rats are still living is to put down some patches of talc
or porathalite, or 10 percent DDT dust, to
make rat tracks easily visible.
A patch of approximately 12 by 18 inches and
about 1/8 inch thick is spread
and smoothed with a straight edge.
Smoothing will make it easier to see the tracks
clearly.
Because rat signs age slowly, it is impossible
to tell from them the progress
of day-to-day eradication.
The tracking patch is the best way of determining the extent of rat activity during a given night.
The tracking patches are laid along the rats' principle routes
between food, water, and harborage.
In view of the rats limited home range, patches must be so placed that every rat present
will traverse some patch during the night.
Too few patches, or patches poorly or patches poorly placed,
can give a false impression that all rats have been killed.
Early the next morning the patches are examined with a flashlight
before the kitchen is cleaned for use.
The first patch is smooth.
This patch clearly shows tracks of several
rats.
The flashlight is held at an angle of about
30 degrees to the floor
so as to throw into relief the impressions in the dust.
Obviously the job is not completed yet, and
by now the surviving rats
have probably developed an aversion to red
squill.
Therefore, the rat control man decides to
use Antu to complete the kill.
Antu is unique in that it can be used as a
tracking poison.
The control man removes the old patches in
order to avoid diluting the Antu mixture.
Antu is specific for Norway rats, while roof
rats have a high tolerance for it.
Next, the control man lays down new patches consisting of a mixture of 20 percent Antu dust
and 80 percent pyrophyllite.
Even though expensive, Antu is economical
when used under ideal conditions.
In this case, the rats have become accustomed
to tracking patches in their runways.
It is virtually certain that the rats will
come into contact with the rodenticide.
In their search for food, the rats run through
the Antu dust.
The dust irritates the rats' paws, causing
them later to lick their paws,
thus ingesting the Antu dust.
Antu causes an over-production of liquid in
the rat's lungs.
Within 48 hours the rat dies as though by
drowning.
When no rat tracks appear on the tracking
patches for five nights,
the eradication man knows the restaurant kitchen
has been freed of rats.
Rats may re-enter a rat-free and rat-proof
building through an open door
or with merchandise deliveries.
To maintain the kitchen in a rat-free condition,
frequent inspection is necessary.
Inspection must be at regularly scheduled
intervals so as to find
any re-infestation as soon as possible.
Sometimes the rodenticide selected does not
work too well.
In this fish market, torpedoes containing
red squill bait have been tried,
but for some reason have proved ineffective.
The surviving rats will no longer take the
red squill bait,
having developed an aversion to it.
Since the rats have been feeding mainly on
fish and fish scraps,
the eradicator decides to use arsenic trioxide in a fish bait.
The arsenic trioxide is added to an emetic,
in this case tartar emetic, and weighed carefully.
The tarter emetic is intended to protect animals
other than rats by causing them
to vomit the poison.
The poison and emetic is added to the
fish.
Finally, the bait is prepared in torpedoes.
As an alternate bait, ground bread crumbs
and ground bacon are mixed
with the finely powered emetic and the arsenic
trioxide.
[Narrator:] This second bait is made into
torpedoes.
Again, contrasting paper is used to distinguish
them from the other bait.
In the fish market, these poisoned baits are
readily taken by the rats.
Arsenic trioxide is a poison which is absorbed
into the rat's intestinal tract
causing gastroenteritis, destruction of kidneys,
exhaustion, and generalized paralysis.
Death usually occurs in less than 24 hours,
although in a few cases
where minimal lethal doses are eaten, it
may take up to six days.
To check on the possibility of any rat surviving,
tracking patches are put down.
In this case, the patch is laid in a 15 inch
radius around the rat hole, making it impossible
for any rat using the hole to avoid leaving
its tracks in the patch.
Thus, well-placed tracking patches offer a
check on the effectiveness
of any specific treatment.
In addition to indicating the presence or
absence of rats, tracks found in such
patches often indicate the size of surviving
rats and the number of rats using the runway.
Such tracks are also a clue to the direction
and purpose of rat travel.
Only when an adequate number of properly placed
tracking patches are free from rat footprints
for five nights in succession can the premises
be considered rat free.
A quick-acting, highly toxic rodenticide such
as 1080 water can be used
only when the premises can be effectively closed off
to humans and animal pets.
When the area contains food, it is necessary
to cut off all sources of water,
and rely on the rat's thirst to force them to take a water-borne poison.
1080 water is placed in water-proof, non-spillable cups.
1080 is a very dangerous poison.
Only trained and experienced eradication men
should be permitted to use it.
The utmost precautions must be taken whenever
1080 is used.
Rats must have water.
1080 water is tasteless, odorless, and quite
acceptable to them.
One swallow is a lethal dose.
1080 kills within one-half to two hours.
For some unknown reason, a high percentage
of rats killed with 1080
die in accessible places and are easily recovered.
Convulsions precede death by heart failure.
[Narrator:] The next day, the first order
of business is to count, pick up,
and dispose of cups and carcasses.
Dead rats and every used 1080 cup should be
incinerated.
Only licensed and qualified eradication men
should be permitted to use 1080,
and then only under carefully supervised conditions.
With 1080 as with other rodenticides, tracking
patches are laid to determine
whether all the rats have been killed.
This basement storage room has been rat-proofed,
but colonies of rats
still remain and have to be exterminated.
The rat control man decides to try another
rat poison, warfarin.
Warfarin was originally known as compound
42.
Strictly speaking, it is an anti-coagulant,causing
a slow bleeding to death.
It is tasteless and odorless.
One effective bait to use with warfarin is
cornmeal mixed with a discoloring agent
such as activated charcoal to warn against
human use.
Warfarin mixed with yellow cornmeal and charcoal
is placed in a bait box
near a rat entrance.
The purpose of the bait box in this case is
not to prevent human access,
but to avoid the poison being kicked and spilled
accidentally.
The use of such a bait box is optional.
The box contains enough bait to last until
the next service date.
A tracking patch is spread around the bait
box to indicate the presence or absence of rats.
Another bait box is located near a place where
the rats have fed in the past.
Tracking patches are placed around this box
also.
During the night the rats are attracted by
the bait, and approach the box.
As no other food is uncovered and easily available,
the rats investigate
and find the food to their liking.
Unlike other poisons, warfarin does not create
an aversion in rats that eat it.
They come back again and again.
Rats often show a preference for warfarin
in cornmeal over other foods,
even though the other is unpoisoned.
The next day, examination of the tracking
patch shows the rats' reactions to the bait.
They have eaten so much that it's necessary
to replenish the supply.
The effect of warfarin is cumulative.
Repeated doses over a period of several days
will gradually weaken the rat
by loss of blood.
The rat usually dies between the fifth and
eighth day.
The slow, cumulative effect of the poison
delays the rat's death for several days.
Thus, warfarin is dangerous to domestic animals
only with repeated ingestion.
Despite its safety features, warfarin must
be used with caution, placed in a bait box,
or in inaccessible locations where humans
and household pets cannot get at it.
With warfarin, just as with all other rodenticides,
tracking patches are needed
to indicate the presence or absence of surviving rats.
For 10 days after the last rat was found dead,
there have been no tracks around the box.
Yet, another patch near the rat entry hole
shows the tracks of more than one surviving rat.
Since warfarin won't complete the job, the
bait boxes are removed,
but the remaining rats must be killed.
The eradicator decides to use steel traps.
He selects one, carefully sets it at hair
trigger, and places it at an opening to rat harborage.
Because the steel trap does not kill the rat
outright, it must be securely fastened
so the rat cannot drag it to his harborage.
To force the rat to cross the trap, the eradicator
puts a box on each side of the trap.
The boxes are pushed back against the platform
to prevent the rat from turning aside
to bypass the trap.
After setting out sufficient traps, he puts
out additional tracking patches
and smooths the old ones.
The next morning, inspection shows that one rat has been caught in a trap and is still alive.
Another trap has evidently been sprung and
dragged around but there is no rat in it.
The tracking patch near the rat entry reveals a rat's footprints.
Since the eradicator now has made the rat
shy of steel traps, he prepares
expanded-trigger wood traps and places them
in the rat runs and near food.
A rat is caught; probably the last rat.
Tracking patches are resmoothed and observed
daily for five days.
Since no rat footprints are found, the storage
basement is considered to be rat-free.
Thereafter, as in all rat-free premises, inspection
must be made at regular intervals.
For this purpose, tracking patches laid in
dark, out-of-the-way places
provide a permanent inspection record.
There are other types of rodenticides and
as time goes on, more will be developed.
But regardless of the rodenticide used, safety
for human beings and small animals,
as well as effectiveness against rats, must
be considered.
For greater safety, an emetic can be added
to many rodenticides.
Dangerous poisons with which emetics cannot
be used should be handled
only by qualified personnel under conditions that present no peril to human beings or domestic animals.
By observing proper rat-killing techniques, ratproof premises
can be completely freed of rats and kept that
way.
Rat-killing by itself, without sanitation
or ratproofing, must often be used
as a temporary, emergency measure.
In sub-standard areas, there are conditions
like these:
garbage, rubbish, rat food, and harborage
everywhere.
Sanitation appears to be unknown.
Obviously, under such conditions ratproofing
is impossible.
Financial help may be needed to improve or
rebuild the sections.
Individual and collective efforts to clean
the place up may take a long time.
Everywhere there is evidence of rat infestation,
carrying with it a constant danger of rat-borne
disease.
There have been several reported cases of
children being bitten by rats.
The health officer and sanitary engineer are
faced with a real problem.
According to latest health inspection reports, three blocks in the area
have the highest incidence of rat bites in
the entire city.
A survey has shown that the same three blocks
are in the center of a large area
that is heavily rat-infested.
Poisoning operations are planned for this
area.
The first rodenticide to be used is red squill, the safest rat poison known for residential areas.
Four baits are selected; fresh fish, fresh
horse meat, rolled oats, and scratch feed.
Each type of poison bait will be prepared
in torpedoes wrapped in a different color paper.
After preparation, the four types of torpedoes are assembled into one pile.
Then they are thoroughly intermingled, so
that when they are distributed,
the rats will have a complete choice of baits.
The assortment is loaded into carrying bags.
To take full advantage of rat habits, poisoning is planned on a block-by-block basis.
The men form a working team.
Each man is assigned a section of the area
to cover.
In any such program, the goodwill and cooperation
of the residents
is an essential factor.
The men must inform the occupants of the purpose
of the work and request them
to confine pets and not to allow children
to molest the poison baits.
Of course with native populations, consideration
must be given to their food habits,
and no baits used which might be eaten under
the compulsion of hunger.
The eradicator then proceeds to look for rat
signs.
At places where he sees rat signs, he deposits
clusters of the four baits.
The occupant of each house is contacted.
The work is explained and consent obtained
for placing the baits.
Experienced rat-control men quickly pick out
rat signs and place the bait accordingly.
Active burrows and signs of gnawing indicate
the need for a generous supply of poison.
Here's a place for many rats.
Rubbish piles are logical places to expect
rat infestation.
Hedgerows and shrubbery are usually honeycombed with rat runs.
The area is thoroughly covered.
Bait is much less expensive than labor and
should be used generously.
At dusk the efforts begin to bear fruit.
The maximum kill is almost always achieved
on the first attempt.
Rats surviving the initial poisoning will
become suspicious and avoid the poisoned bait.
This initial area of poisoning, therefore,
must be thorough.
Not only must the dwelling areas be covered,
but the surrounding territory also.
Poisoning must be extended to adjoining, open
areas that are reservoirs of rat infestation.
Poison baits are distributed systematically,
block by block, until the entire area is treated.
After a week, an inspection is made of the
area.
Reports are collected on the results of the
poisoning program.
Reports show that results were satisfactory
in more than 90 percent of the blocks treated.
The remaining areas must be treated again.
For the re-poisoning, zinc phosphide is used with tartar emetic added.
A new group of materials will be mixed with
the poison.
This time it is mixed with cubed apples.
Zinc phosphide causes gastrointestinal irritation,
cerebral involvement,
and liver injury, usually causing death within
12 hours.
As always, the poison is carefully measured
out.
In re-poisoning, each step must be repeated.
The change in rodenticides is explained to
all householders,
and the safety factor in the tartar emetic
is pointed out.
The men work swiftly but carefully, seeking
out rat signs and distributing
a generous supply of the poisoned bait.
The re-poisoning was successful and accomplished
with temporary control
sought through area poisoning, but much remains
to be done.
In order for the beneficial effects to last
as long as possible,
the inspector must instruct householders on
how to cut down available rat food
and to remove rat harborages.
Education and enforcement in sanitation must
be constant and progressive.
The inspector studies the evidence of rat
infestation on each premise
before contacting the occupant.
Thus, he will be able to make specific suggestions
on solving the particular problems
of each premise.
One successful device in this educational
work is to tag inadequate garbage cans
to emphasize to the owner that replacement is required.
A specific suggestion might be the removal
of a board fence or elimination of shrubbery
giving the rats access to open windows.
A courteous and constructive approach to the
residents will usually evoke interest
and full cooperation.
Several weeks later, three blocks out of 41
originally poisoned
require additional treatment and are scheduled for re-poisoning.
To keep down the rat population in substandard
areas is a never-ending job,
as long as environmental conditions make
available the basic requirements
for rat life; namely food and harborage.
In the long run, substandard housing must
be eliminated, and new construction
of rat-proof design provided.
[Music]
When sanitary practices become habitual, depriving
rats of their food supply,
when ratproof buildings are erected, and maintained
in good repair,
reducing rat harborage,
then, rat-killing becomes the final and conclusive measure in an integrated program of rat control.
[Music]